Zach Miller's the Bears tight end and
perhaps the last time you saw Zach was
in a game where he thought he had caught
a touchdown pass against the Saints so
did we and then you realized when he
came down landing awkwardly that it
looked like he was in trouble from just
a knee injury regular knee injury and
then I didn't know if he had broken it
and then social media took over where
all of a sudden it went from knee injury
is it a broken leg too maybe he's
running the risk of losing his leg to
amputation eight surgeries I believe
later Zach Miller kind enough to join us
Zach how's your morale today morale is
high my friends I'm doing good man I
appreciate you having me on all right
let's go back to the play itself
have you seen when's the first time you
saw the play itself I haven't seen it
from an angle that this shows my leg I
saw our video guy got it got an angle
from it for me to be able to see without
my leg being bent backwards but I
haven't seen the actual picture or video
of it being in real time event that way
but when you so you get injured you come
down and at what point do you realize
this is different than any other time
I've ever come down on the ground
I felt I mean I felt the injury right
away obviously I felt I knew was it was
severe I didn't know that I had the
artery injury until probably you know a
couple minutes down the road where I
could start to feel that blood fill up
in the in the bottom of my leg started
to lose a little bit of feeling so that
was kind of the point where I started a
little bit and then do you hear anything
because you're on the ground or you're
being taken off on a stretcher and the
ambulance what do you what are you
hearing at the time you know once it got
me on the stretcher I was kinda on the
sideline I kept hearing the crowd booing
and on because it kept replaying Bri
plan to play and showing an injury every
time so I could hear that I'm like I
didn't know they were reviewing it
clearly I see I have a touchdown so I
thought you know it was up and we'd be
kicking an extra point but they kept
replaying it
I was pretty aware of everything
just you know as time went on it was a
little more urgent for me to get in to
get into the hospital and get some care
going do you think you were in shock at
the time he didn't even realize it yeah
because we immediately when it happened
I was fairly calm I remember sitting in
the end zone talking to her head
athletic trainer Nate brettski and I'll
just tell him to say hey man my knees
gone and he was like you sure like him
and I he knows I know my body pretty
well so you know I was calm all the way
up until the point we got back to the
locker room and then you know once that
my legs started to feel the way it did
the panic kind of started to set in how
long was the initial surgery I think
like four or five hours it was the the
first one to repair the artery and stuff
I'm in had to take take a vein out of
the other side of my leg and then they
flip you over cut you in the back of
your leg and repair the artery that was
about four or five hours and then these
subsequent surgeries what had they been
yes those were so I had a fasciotomy of
my calf on both sides where they just
make incisions you know really from the
bottom of the knee to the top of the
ankle just to relieve the pressure that
had guys so much blood loss and trauma
so the fluid that was filling up a mic
and my calf with a compartment syndrome
needed to be released and that's really
what the majority of the surgeries were
for was just to to make sure that was
draining and get it closed up talking to
Zach Miller the Bears tight end joining
us Dan Patrick show you heard the word
amputation were you told that or how did
that topic come how was that presented
to you I mean it wasn't it wasn't told
to me like okay we got to get this done
or we're gonna have to amputate your leg
I knew knew what could could be if we
didn't get it taken care of
urgently and that was the case I mean we
were we were very close after I woke up
from surgery talking with my with my
doctors and my surgeons you know we're a
matter of midway from you know starting
to lose lose some of that tissue and
once that starts just kind of hard to
stop what was that like I think you have
a daughter and two sons
they come to see dad in the hospital
what was like when they showed up yeah
that was awesome you know for me to see
them the first time for the was actually
when I transported back to Chicago via
airplane so they met me at the airport
it was pretty cool to see them for the
first time it had been a little over
seven or eight days so that was a
special moment for me to get out of them
where's that football from that catch
that should have been a touchdown and
it's getting painted our our Jenner are
our owner George McCaskey delivered that
to me in the hospital the day after my
surgery he that guy's been unbelievable
throughout this whole whole ordeal for
myself and my family but he delivered it
to me and then now it's getting painted
so as soon as it gives decorators eyes
I'll have it back in my possession did
you try to petition the NFL for a
ceremonial touchdown I don't think I
needed to petition that I think a lot of
anybody who goes through surgery
certainly athletes need that carrot
dangled there you need to have some kind
of inspiration like this is my goal I'm
assuming at your age and playing this
sport football is still a possibility at
least in your mind is certainly yeah is
that your goal that your you think
you'll be able to play again I think so
I mean I haven't really told anybody yes
or no whether you know whether that's a
definitive thing for me it's kind of I
have told no I've actually been told yes
by a number of doctors and for me it's
just we'll cross that road when it comes
time but deep down inside I've told
everybody you know who really knows me
they know what I'm about they know I
love playing this game and if I have an
opportunity to do it I'm put everything
I got into it to get back on the field
what's that conversation with your wife
like it's a little
you know she's she she obviously loves
you know what this game has done for us
and and she loves being a part of it
none of this would be possible without
her I mean for her to really raise a
household on her own half the time
throughout the year because football
takes up so much time but it's just
something that's a part of us so you
know either which way however it plays
out I've had a great time doing what
I've done so far but I'd love to
continue it and when that time comes uh
we'll see what happens yeah you know
when you sit down and you know the
questions coming from your wife or
question like you you know it yeah you
know and you could tell that she's
getting ready to ask you and you got to
go oh god I don't know what to say right
you got to tell her like hey babe let's
just play it out we'll see how it goes
that's that's the kind of thing for me
to get her out of this we'll see we'll
cross that road when it when it comes to
me but I know she she worries about me
obviously more after this thing just
just because of you know the way it
played out the severity of it a little
little worrisome obviously for her but
she's been great throughout shoot the
first you know these seven weeks that
we've been going through this she stayed
in the hospital with me for 24 days
bouncing back and forth to take care of
the kids and take care of me so now
she's got another another big kid on her
plate down okay you know sometimes
people Joe okay it's too soon to joke
about that but have your teammates are
they allowed to joke about this at all
hey man anything goes in this line of
work Zack you almost lost your leg yeah
I know nobody's nobody has been over the
top everybody's been actually really
supportive but the the bleacher report
gridiron heights video that came out I
don't know if you got a chain know that
it was it's a funny cartoon if they did
I'll be able to check it out but I got
some good last out of that for my
teammates oh well it'll be a different
Christmas for you but
hopefully it's a great Christmas for you
we appreciate your time Zack and I plan
on seeing you out on on the field
you got a min I hate you I hope you have
a good Christmas as well Thank You Zack
that Zack Miller the Bears tight end and
eight surgeries later seems like he's in
pretty good spirits there seven weeks
ago and then you know you have that
injury and he comes down and you go oh
that's different and then you realize
they're not gonna even give him the
touchdown
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]